I have known George Stevens jr. for a
very long time George and I have worked
together on films and for the causes
that we both believe in and when you
work with George Stevens art and
activism I never very far apart George
is an extraordinary person if he commits
to something he will he's absolutely
fearless in 1967 I got a call from
George he had a vision and it was very
clear to him that vision became the
American Film Institute I am proud to
have served as the inaugural vice
chairman of the board of AFI alongside
Gregory Peck
something you may not know about
George's that he is also an extremely
gifted director I had the unique
privilege of being directed by both
George and separate-but-equal and by his
father in the greatest story ever told
when I worked with a my immediately
understood how George feels about film
it is and part and actors are artists
equal to the great pages and composers
on behalf of the Academy and actors
everywhere I am proud to present this
honorary Oscar to George Stevens Junior